emily you know what movie i haven't seen
of yours that
that you know that made a ton of money
the one you did with tom cruise
for some reason you haven't seen that
movie i've never seen that
oh yeah do you like action movies do you
like i love action movies
and he would love this yeah tom is so
brilliant in it
he's not the earnest action hero he's a
total coward
he's funny he's like wily coyote he's so
good in it it's my favorite thing he's
done but
i would think going on set with a guy
who is successful like tom cruise
would be on the nervous meter no that
that one i was scared for
and i had to get into this um
sort of crazy physical shape for it
because she's supposed to be this
lethal warrior so i was in training for
three months beforehand
and i know that he you know is big into
doing his own action and i thought well
i'm gonna have to try and keep
up and do all of that but i was
bricking it i was scared i also was
scared that i thought it was going to be
boys club you know it's all male
producers male director male writers
tom cruise male cast predominantly and
that's usually to be honest that's been
my experience with
a bunch of movies i've done it's been
quite dominated male dominated but
this one i did not it was one of the
first experience i've had where i was
completely brought into the fold
creatively
and i was in every script meeting and
every single change that was made and
i was treated like gold on it even
though my body was like battered around
every day on that movie and i still have
an injury from it but
it was an amazing experience the hardest
thing i've ever done but it was amazing
in other words it's scary for an actress
for a woman
to go on a set in a traditionally male
run business those guys get together in
a little think tank after every little
shot after every little scene they have
a collaboration
and you're sort of stuck sitting on the
sidelines and not included
as a woman you can get what you want and
you can get your point across
but you gotta dance around a bit more
and i still feel that there's a sort of
need to slightly
contort and accommodate and make sure
you can be really nice about it and like
you can't be too direct because you're
too direct well then you're ambitious
god forbid you sound ambitious or sort
of tough you know
so i always get there now and
i feel i can be much more direct now and
it won't be taken the wrong way it will
just be accepted as like
no i'm not throwing weight around i'm
just telling you this is not how it's
going to go
but now i think i've earned my stripes
creatively as well so everything i do
going forward now i will produce it
because then they have to listen but i
come
with ideas i will rewrite scenes and
people are very open to it now when a
movie's so big like
that with tom cruise has he ever asked
you to do a sequel is there a talk of
such a thing
uh we wanted to honestly i think the
movie is too expensive
i just don't know how yeah i don't know
how we're going to do it and
i think that it's hard to align
everyone's schedules
and i would love it doug lyman would
love it tom would love it
we'd all love to do it but i don't i
think until we figure out what's going
on with the industry honestly i think we
need to figure out
what is the next roadmap for the kinds
of films that people want to make
you